now to Walter son who's the CEO of L
Marine minerals he joins us live now
from Stanga H good to have you with us
Walter uh we hear a lot about the
potential for deep sea mining in the
Pacific and the ongoing debate and
controversy about that this is for
Norwegian Waters what would you expect
to extract
there yeah in Norwegian Waters thank you
so much first for inviting me um in
Norwegian Waters we will have a slightly
different type of deposits than in the
Pacific so here we have the so-called
manganese crust which are quite thick in
Norway and they are highly enriched with
Cobalt and several other Rare Earth
minerals uh needed for the green
transition and then we have the the the
sulfides the seed massive sulfides which
have copper uh sink and Cobalt so that's
the minerals we have nor way you will
you'll know that there's been endless
controversy about this there's a huge
amount of opposition to it and their
argument is that very little is known
about the deep sea bed and that we need
to close that knowledge gap before we
start issuing licenses like this are we
putting the cart before the horse we
should be doing more scientific research
to totally understand what's at
stake well I think we can do both I mean
we we agree with also what the Norwegian
state says that we should have a
precautionary principle on this we agree
that um there are knowledge gaps on the
especially on the environment but also
on the resources especially in Norway so
the way we will do it in Norway is that
we will the industry together with the
government and Research Institute will
spend the next say five to eight years
exploring for the resources and at the
same time map the uh map the deep and
marine environment and you mean
exploring but not
extracting exactly not extracting
because all although in one way there is
a green light for extracting also but
first we need to find the resources and
see that are commercial and then we will
need to have a plan presented for the
parliament with also an impact study
assessment to show that this can be done
with an acceptable impact on nature but
nobody in Europe when you're a lone
voice in Europe the EU commission has
expressed strong concerns about the
environmental impact of the plans uh 120
European parliaments have written open
letter to Norwegian Parliament asking
them to vote against it they said that
the assessment conducted by the
Norwegian government has too many gaps
then and this is important more than 800
ocean scientists have called for a pause
on deep sea mining globally not this
kind of legislation that allows it to
proceed so what do you what is it that
you and other and parliamentarians in
Norway who aren't uh deep SE scientists
aren't marine biologists know that those
scientists
don't well we I think you have to say
that that the moror moratorium which
people are talking about is for Mining
and not for moratorium for expiration
and in Norway there will be a long face
with expiration and we all agree we need
more data but at the same time we know
that the green transition will need huge
amount of minerals and when you say no
to something you're saying yes to
something else as we know for instance
that significant part of new nickel will
come from Indonesian rainforest so we
mean or think that the oil and gas
offshore oil and gas industry has the
technology to Har or to mine or explore
and mine for the deep sea mineral that's
what we like to see uh make the chance
to see what we if we can achieve uh by
saying no we will we will not be able to
even test out our um Theory also to see
if we can develop technology and for our
company we see already we have made um
uh big achievement on coming up with
technology both on exploration and
actually on production that minimize the
the environmental impact and we we like
to work together with others to show
what we are doing okay many there of
course worried very worried about the
Legacy that you're setting here but
we'll leave it there for now Walter son
appreciate that thanks very much and D
for joining us here in aler